A new knitter recently
shared her goal sweater.
She told me that the hand knitting pattern
she wanted to use was
a slip stitch pattern.
But looking closely at the photo,
it's a slip rib pattern incorporating
both knit and purl stitches.
She has an LK150 knitting machine,
so we offered her some options.
The hand knitting stitch pattern is written
row 1, knit 3,
slip one purl-wise, row 2, purl
across the row, and repeat these rows.
We can translate this to machine knitting,
keeping in mind that the purl stitches are
always facing us on our knitting machine.
How about hand-manipulating every
fourth stitch to create that slip rib?
Here are two methods on a manual machine.
First, knit about 10 rows and then
manually drop every fourth stitch.
When relatching each column
of stitches, skip a row.
This will cause the stitch
to elongate and produce this result.
For the second method,
I left every fourth needle out of work
and then manually latched up the ladders,
again skipping every other row,
elongating in the knit
stitch on that purl background.
Please try both of these methods
to determine which one you prefer.
Dropping and relatching the stitches
created a looser and wider fabric.
When keeping needles out of work,
the strands forming the ladders are
tighter, and the resulting fabric
is also tighter and narrower.
If you have a ribber, you can make
short work of this stitch pattern.
Set up your needles like this, having
every fourth needle on the main bed.
This will create a three by one rib.
Then set your main bed
to slip in one direction.
This will form those elongated
stitch columns automatically.
This technique can also be worked
on the ribber as Flat Rib.
Keeping all needles in work on one bed
and every fourth needle on the opposite
bed, slipping every other row.
Slipped rib is a versatile technique
that can have lots of uses.
Try it with your machine
and see which method you prefer.